nicolas glières bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors je
le disais à selon le haut conseil pour
la santé publique que les enfants sont
peu susceptibles de se contaminer entre
eux et de contaminer les adultes pour
vous cet avis ne permet pas pour autant
d'alléger le protocole sanitaire c'est
bien cela tout à fait la situation est
préoccupante tout le monde le dit les
chiffres sont de plus en plus grave la
situation s'aggrave et notre
gouvernement d'incapables qui navigue à
vue
effectivement prend des mesures est des
mesures en courant après l'actualité du
jour est tout le temps dépassée par les
événements et ne protège pas les
personnels et nous met même en danger
il faut quand même savoir qu'une classe
est un cluster géant
que ce soit en primaire au collège au
lycée ou à l'université
on entasse 35 élèves par classe avec des
masques qui sont des slips
concrètement qui ne protège pas s'est
avéré les enfants contaminés comme les
autres de ce que je sache l'allemagne la
corée du sud n'ont pas de plus mauvais
scientifique que les nôtres chez nous
c'est complètement le bazar à ce niveau
là personne n'est d'accord il y a un
véritable don j'ai pour tous élèves
parents étudiants enseignants personnels
d'éducation famille alors du coup qu'est
ce que vous proposez vous très
concrètement notamment pour les petites
classes aujourd'hui pour toutes les
classes pour l'université comprise nous
proposons le demi groupes comme c'était
le cas on met avec prise en charge des
élèves de l'autre demie groupe par les
mairies numérique on les personnels
adéquats l'éducation nationale peut
recruter aussi on est en période de
chômage
donc ça ferait du travail pour les gens
et ce sera un travail utile au contraire
d'autres
donc franchement il ya des solutions
concrètes pragmatiques raisonnable et le
gouvernement refuse de les entendre
depuis juin nous on propose cela depuis
juin c'est simple 2000 groupe pour tous
les élèves de la maternelle à l'achat qu
est ce que vous vous sentez soutenus par
les parents face à cet assouplissement
des règles que vous contestez
les parents sont perdus on leur donne
des informations complètement conrad
contradictoires on demande à la
population de plus en plus de ne pas se
rassembler porter des masques partout
même dans des rues gide et en même temps
on explique à 35 dans une classe il n'y
a pas de danger mais que les personnels
les personnels notamment d'éducation en
danger
il doit le mettre un masque chirurgical
dont il y à une incohérence totale dans
la manière de présenter les faits les
parents sont perdus et nous nous leur
disons que nous voulons empêcher un
confinement d'avoir lieu c'est pour cela
que nous demandons en demi groupe pour
empêcher le confinement alors avec les
stylos rouges vous avez décidé de porter
l affaire en justice
quel est votre objectif l'objectif c'est
tout simplement faire plier le pouvoir
que le pouvoir entendre raison on a
affaire à des incapables dogmatique ils
sont entre dub mais stupidité
visiblement ils sont incapables de
prendre une décision cohérente
les décisions ne vont pas du tout dans
le bon sens elle ne protège personne
personne n'était à l'abri de ce virus ce
virus tue je vous rappelle trente et une
personnes sont mortes
c'est le même chiffre qu'au etats-unis
en pourcentage à peu de choses près donc
c'est une catastrophe et c'est très mal
gérée en france en italie en espagne aux
etats-unis au brésil
on a à peu près à chiens à la même chose
on a un ministre jean michel blanquer
dans le déni de la réalité il a expliqué
qu on aime on était rentrés dans la joie
c'est quand même un petit trump en
version light enfin on allait là même le
même type de personne concrètement ce
sont des gens qui sont dangereux qui
nous mettent en danger
ils doivent être jugés ils doivent
répondre de leurs actes sont des
responsables ils doivent l'être en même
temps il faut vous comprenez bien qu'il
faut aussi continuer l'éducation des
enfants c'est important également malgré
cette pandémie tout à fait la première
victime était un enseignant française
était un enseignant de 59 ans dans
l'oise deux élèves dans un lycée ont
créé un cluster géant avec 72 malades en
quelques jours ça c'était en mars
alors bien sûr que l'éducation est
essentielle mais quand on fait en 2000
groupe ça veut dire qu'ils viennent un
jour sur deux à l'école et l'autre demi
journée ils ont cours à distance
donc c'est tout à fait faisable il n'y a
pas de déficit d'éducation dans ce cas
là on met ça s'est très bien passé en
jouant aussi on ne sacrifie pas la santé
et la vie des concitoyens au nom d'une
valeur travail certes importante mais
qui ne doit pas tuer alors autre
interrogation vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure ans et celle concernant les
masques à la semaine dernière des
masques en tissu ont été fournies par
fournis par l'éducation nationale avait
été décriée par un syndicat du primaire
il est jugé pas assez protecteur alors
qu'est ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui est
ce que vous avez eu des retours
aucun nous n'avons toujours aucun masque
chercher chirurgicale donner
concrètement on nous donne toujours ses
slips dim
il faut savoir que ces masques il est
écrit dessus qu'il ne protège pas qu'ils
ne sont pas des outils médicaux
concrètement donc c'est incroyable il
faut aussi savoir que les enseignants de
primaire dans mon parti quasiment alors
qu'ils sont seuls face aux élèves à être
masqué les élèves ne le sont pas ces
petits qui sont censés ne pas être
ontanon ne porte rien touche les tables
touchent leur nez tous dessus crache
dessus
les tables dans une salle de classe très
concrètement ne sont lavés que le soir
donc ce sont ces tables elles-mêmes sont
des clusters les salles de cours sont
des clusters les cantines sans masques
sont des clusters les cours d'école et
les couloirs sont des clusters des
élèves qu'ils soient à dos ou enfants se
font des câlins s'embrassent retire leur
masse que touche tous c'est dangereux
c'est un fait il n'y a aucune hygiène et
sécurité
on a à faire une rentrée normale alors
que le coït sévit de plus en plus alors
bientôt trois semaines que les élèves
sont revenus en classe pour conclure est
ce que vous avez eu des retours sur
l'état d'esprit des enseignants à ce
qu'il ya davantage de stress comment
est-ce qu'ils sont accompagnés
le stress est énorme là cette rentrée
épuisante
vraiment c'est pas pour se plaindre mais
cher cours avec un masque ce n'est pas
être devant un ordi devant un masque ça
je peux vous le jurer je vous propose
d'essayer de parler pendant deux heures
avec un masque dans une salle
surchauffée pas erré vous verrez ce que
ça donne on est épuisé on est
nerveusement affectés on est inquiets
pour nos élèves on est inquiets pour
nous même inquiet pour les familles on
ne sait pas qui est responsable aussi en
cas de contamination sur scène c'est
très inquiétant puisque nos ministres
sont irresponsables éternellement de
tous nos chefs sont très souvent
irresponsables éternellement de tout
donc on ne sait pas vraiment vers qui se
tourner c'est pour cela qu'on est obligé
d'attaquer messieurs veron et blanc
caire pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui c'est ce qu'ils font merci
beaucoup nicolas glières d'avoir répondu
à nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant et membre des stylos rouges